you celebrate today after mps gave their
support for the bill sky's either
bennett reports
[Music]
instead of the usual protest outside
parliament today there was celebration
after mps insight gave their support to
what's believed to be a world first
legislation that will guarantee people
with down syndrome get the care and
services they need
it's been something that needs to be
done for a long time really bobby and
her daughter brogan travelled from
guildford to witness the moment they
hope it'll end the stigma around down
syndrome which they say is a constant
battle i tried to get broken into a
local dance group when she was about six
or seven and as soon as i said she had
down syndrome the lady that ran things
said she was better off sticking with
her own kind rather than going into a
mainstream dance group we did find a
fantastic maintenance dance group after
that but that was just the first
sort of hurdle that i was quite
surprised
it is not
on our part an act of charity it is an
act of empowerment
former cabinet minister liam fox
proposed the bill which provides a legal
guarantee for people with down syndrome
to have their needs met in health
education and crucially social care this
is the first generation to outlive their
parents which until today has been the
source of daily concern for anjali and
simon hoyle over who will care for their
three-year-old son dexter
it's a historic day because us as
parents to a child who has down syndrome
um we you know hope and pray he's going
to outlive us
he has siblings but now there's going to
be legislation in place to take care of
him when he you know through his
education also when he's older there's a
small step for parliament but it's a
massive step for the down syndrome
community for the down syndrome
community this is a major victory
because it addresses not only a lack of
provision but also a lack of
understanding that is very long overdue
as the campaigners say it will allow
people with down syndrome to show what
they're truly capable of on that front
the sky really is the limit iva bennett
sky news westminster